yeah thank you very much uh Miss Casey
um welcome to the uh the Southeastern
area planning committee meeting
um my name is councilor Adrian Fluker
I'm the ward member for southminster I'm
the vice chairman of this committee the
chairman sent this apologies so I will
be chairing the meeting this evening
um
apologies for absence please miss Casey
noise and schemes
and if I can just add counselor Duke if
you didn't say it
lovely
um okay members uh General items three
minutes of the last meeting
can we agree those
thanks very much
um disclosures of Interest members
[Music]
um
I'm afraid I haven't got an agenda and I
haven't got connection to the um the
internet so I'm so uh
that's very kind
so a gender item four to disclose the
existence and nature of any disclosable
peculiar interests other Regional
interests and non-regional interests
related into items of business on the
agenda have in regard to paragraph 9 and
appendix B of the code of conduct for
members members
um I actually have a disclosable
interest in uh agenda item six
um Gemini
I'm uh a member of South Minster Parish
Council so
um what I can do uh under the new code
of conduct
I can speak and then leave the meeting
so I shall be doing that
um but that leaves us in a difficult
position because obviously we are going
to have to appoint a chairman for that
part of the meeting so
um Mr Casey what I'd like to do whilst
we're talking about this now I'd like to
go through that process and I think
that'll make it easier when we get to a
gender item six because I can speak and
then leave so
um I will now call for nominations for
chairman for Isom 6 and proposed cancer
stem right okay so Council stamps is now
going to deal with item six so we'll go
to item five as it's on the agenda I'll
just let everybody know what happened uh
that was inadvertently put on to uh the
agenda of this meeting and
should have been on North West
so we'll now go to a general item six
King George the Fifth playing field
so I asked Mr doe to do his presentation
thank you very much
is foreign
in terms of the um
setting up the site there's one or two
things which
I will point out
um
this is the uh the block plan perhaps
before I go to that I will refer to the
wider Scale map I don't so I don't play
victims in my
cut us up moving about on the screen
there but I will point out that the
summit is as marked in red as you will
see from your map there is a
an access on the second side of High
Street
um
those of you that know the access know
that it it's it's quite for access
but it's in the conservation area it's
been there there's there's no scope to
improve it
with regard to the access apologies
chair but I don't want to stray up
corset but before I forget
since the members update the
concentration response from Council
highways has now been received and
um in essence
it says on balance therefore from a
highway and transportation perspective
the impact of The Proposal is acceptable
to the highway Authority
so we've got the the access there
uh there's a totally green
um
here where the cursor is moving around
to the northeast of the position of the
proposed building
some tennis courts three tennis courts
to the South Bowling Green
there's some residential development
over to the Northeast we've got passion
Chase
a primary school West Australia
an open field to the south of that
out of residential development is
vicarage Court over to the West
there is a
site and special scientific interest
to the South just stop the test of the
map being displayed
um and finally with regard to this map
I'd just like to point out that the
settlement boundary
runs to the South for houses along Touch
of schools
posts and then goes
east west where the building would be
positioned
the proposed building is just outside
the settlement boundary
moving to the block plan
uh
you'll see that the position of the
proposed field who is to the south of
the tennis courts
the settlement boundary follows the
fence the southernmost points of the
tennis courts
the building would be where the cursor
is moving it would be on the position of
a multi-use gaming area
is an image of the proposed building
um
brickwork to the level of the first
floor Sills
I don't know if you can see that there's
quite an interesting group feature in
the the roof surface would project
forward
on this the uh the front elevation
this is coming back to the position of
the uh of the building the front
entrance would be the north renovation
uh has just displayed
and here is the elevational drawings of
the of the front elevation the
um the north elevation
there would be uh
uh a picture under the Gable
um quite a simple building
um fairly swap proportions but uh Reddit
the architect has broken it
the building up into different elements
mainly through the group form I'll go to
the
side elevation
this is the west elevation you'll see
that the route that gets forward over
the entrance
along this elevation this is close to
the hedge of the field to the West
on this slide I'd like to point out the
um on the right hand side there there
would be an external staircase well I I
say external it would be poems by AIDS a
mesh work type company and that would
provide a screen to
about to be a Terrace area which is
shown on this which is the East
Elevation
recessed under the roof on the left hand
side of the slides there would be a
balcony area
balcony terrorists call it what you will
this is the real elevation the elevation
overlooking the football pitches
and if you'll see that there's about the
area at first floor level
recessed into the form of the building
and you'll see that there's a mesh
arrangement to the left hand side there
so there would be views to the rear to
the South
some sort of view to the east
the staircase and it's imposure would
scream to the West
oh
this ground floor plan
the entrance the main entries would be
on the right hand side of the screen
you'll see there's a multi-use function
room
for team changing rooms
sacraments are United FC
um use the the pictures
at the moment
um
you'll catch an idea of the proportions
the dimensions of the building there
moving to the first floor
you'll see that as individual changing
rooms A gym dance studio an upstairs
function room
um that would have
a very small bar you'll you can see that
where the cut the cursor is moving now
you'll see it's not much larger than the
width of the door to the right-hand side
um the function room and then leading on
to the Terrace the balcony area
um
very pleasant Arrangement staircase is
top left hand corner there
is a photo of what would be replaced by
the proposed building
um the proposed building would go on the
left hand side you can just see the edge
of multi-use area you can see the
lighting colonies on that
enough a genuine white a few of what
would be replaced
foreign
that is essentially the uh the proposal
chair but if there's any questions
um
I will of course answer those thank you
chair I'm sure they will be
um Miss Casey can you just confirm
whether or not you've got any other
speakers registered to speak other than
uh Council Anderson
love you
okay so uh councilor Anderson if you'd
like to come forward and you've got two
minutes
um to speak to this proposal
okay so speaker Laura yeah no no you're
fine just sit yourself down thank you
right this project started in
2019 as a sketch on a piece of paper of
an idea but for years been trying to get
a decent building in the village and
we've been blocked Time and Time Again
by previous members of the council
in the end I contacted
um building trust spoke to them about
what we wanted to do they said it sounds
okay send in a sketch of what you want
and I said yeah okay go ahead and do
some basic plans and come to us one
thing we will say is do not exceed
the existing footprint of the existing
four buildings
we then had discussions with um not MDC
preamp and where to cite it for
views of
noise impact etc etc
we went ahead and
did this finally got this last plan it
did actually exceed the
um
parameters of the what
was said by
fills in trust but then when we told
them showed them what the plans were and
the size and the amount it
over over uh lacked what we were told
they accepted it and said fine go ahead
let us know when you get planning
permission
so now we're in the position where we've
worked hard South minster is a village
that's expanding
it deserves a decent facility we believe
this is the beginning of a good facility
for the village
and I hope
I hope that it is acceptable to this
committee
uh it's been hard work harder work
happens now if we do get playing with
funding so that's it I think thank you
thank you very much bang on and no notes
to be commended
um
um all I would like to add to that is is
that there was some question about uh
access which I believe now has been been
dealt with and I would ask members to
look at paragraph 3.2.1 and uh and I
hope members that you will see uh fixes
support this and not least of all is the
existing facilities on the field of very
heavily used they're very dilapidated
and they definitely need replacing to
bring them up to speed
um
cancer stamp I've not put the
recommendation and I'll leave that up to
you so I'll now vacation
thank you so much
okay members the officer's
recommendation for this agenda item is
to approve subject to conditions as
detailed in section eight
um do I have a I propose do I have a
secondary councilor Helm Miss Casey did
you get I propose and councilor Helm
seconded it please
okay I'll now open the um agenda item Up
For Debate members do we have any
questions cancel the Bell please thank
you um The Madam chair just I've been
looking at it it's not the most
beautiful thing you will ever see but as
far as a gropius found with that house
said full follows function it's a sports
center it does what it says on the team
and I think we can all say and I think
some of us have you know are very
familiar with the current facilities and
like I can't see this doing anything
other than adding to
well adding to the facilities in
southminster and um Council of Luca and
perhaps around the Civil Rights South
minister is a growing Village it
deserves a decent facility so yeah I'm
happy to support this thank you thank
you councilor Bell
um councilor Channel
and the condition regarding asleep
I went on the website and I read that
details before there's seen quite a
number of things where they had concerns
about
I'm going to start skiing those other
things and they mentioned refer to
flooding
um and they seem to mention a condition
at the end of the left of the low star
no objections subject to a condition
prior to construction above the damp
proof course
asking for
um something other for the trains Works
including I think connection I can't
remember all the way I tried to score a
bit down before I came can we just be
assured that everything in the ending in
water correspondence is dealt with by
the conditions on this application
because the number of things did seem
quite concerning the way they earned it
thank you
well Madam chairman we had comments from
both anglian water and environmental
health and I think it's fair to say the
environmental health were perhaps even
more screen treated and the comments of
his part of mental health were picked up
in the conditions on the agenda Mr Larry
have you found the conditions yeah
I said it's more owners data has to be
submitted yeah um are you reassured
Council of China
by then what you're saying is the
environmental health
yeah yes okay that Council Helm would
you like to say anything no I agree with
the proposal okay well let's not delay
I'd like to put the The Proposal again
that we um accept the officer's
recommendation show of hands please
motion carried thank you somebody like
to bring Council filter back in thank
you very much
all right and we'll just we're just a
journal wait for five minutes please
okay
Adrian do you still on my agenda are you
okay
yeah no no no it's all working
amazing
are we streaming
yes it's back on I've just had him I
just had a message there you go so we're
now going to go to a gender item seven
which is application number
22.008964 Homeland southminster Road
ashram
cm07dz Miss Matthews over to you
access
Homeland establishment
which plan shows the location of the
site
um
Southwest Road existing house openings
is there on the
um
attention to the update that was being
so collectible for a meeting which
includes consultation and responses from
Burnham Town Council and Essex County
personal
services absolutely
thank you
this is location plan again showing the
uh
and the new access which would
um
to the north of the house
and this is a Chicago celebration floor
plan again shows access to Road Buffalo
es two bedrooms
Garage on there
elevations
[Music]
upside down
yeah
photos so this is um the bottom one is a
Bend and your home Max in the background
there the existing house and then you've
got two photos up here
left showing where the new access would
be and then you've also got another
photo that's taken on and off up and
down and so we've got the application
side is just on the
application and
um it's considered that the um
proposal is is unacceptable and partly
due to the location of the site
being in the ground being accessible by
means other than a private car and
issues related to the
development on character parents are the
areas
and in the absence of a completed
investment undertaking to
um
security
the brand is also recommended for that
reason for that reason as well
um
on this site because back to an
application in 2016 and whereby I was an
application for two Chalet Bungalows
which was dismissed on appeal and
reference to the lack of space between
the dwellings was raised by the
inspector the Suburban character that we
would create and the erosion of the
royal character
and and it was also commented about the
exacerbation of these impacts with the
prominence the site on the on the sharp
end
patient and
thank you very much
um I understand as one public speaker Mr
Mark Rickards that's right thanks if
you'd like to come over here and sit
down and uh see if you can sit by the
microphone then people can hear you at
home
and you've got and when you start you've
got two minutes yeah I've got I've got a
lot to say that we've got so you've got
two minutes I'll be nice and clear
excuse me so we're just we're just
waiting to get the clock up that's why
you it should be okay
once the clock comes up
right ready Mr Rickard it's all yours
The Bungalow will be occupied by the
applicant's grandson and his partner
enabling them to remain living there
contributing to the life and vitality of
the village and Rural economy
the home is considered of modest design
providing residents the space they need
now and in the future
it will be energy efficient with solar
panels a ground Source heat pump rain
water harvesting and electric vehicle
charging points electric vehicles would
be used along with the existing bus
service
externally will be free landscaped
improving visual character of this
corner plot it's currently overgrown and
untidy and used for storing materials
and plant
the site is not isolated in open
Countryside it's located within the
cartilage of the existing dwelling
within a small group of other
Residential Properties
it's not considered to harm the open
appearance of the countryside
the proposed single dwelling would still
make positive contribution to the
council's housing Target
as the council cannot achieve a
five-year housing land Supply government
policy provides a clear presumption in
favor of sustainable development
the council has never requested a
unilateral undertaking to validate the
application however the applicant has
submitted a signed and dated copy to the
council
we've heard this morning that the
council now requires a checking fee
which the applicant is willing to pay
but the council will require time to
check the document
therefore if the committee would be
prepared to Grant permission could the
decision be left in the Chairman's hands
for the agreement to be checked
government policy requires land to be
used effectively and this proposal
complies with that
having regards the decision of the
planning inspectors in The Wider area it
is considered that this this needs the
all the overarching objectives of
sustainable development
I would respectfully ask you on behalf
of the applicants have regards the
parish council's recommendation of
support as for our planning permission
subject to appropriate conditions thank
you
so if you'd like to go back to the
public Gallery that'll be great thank
you
foreign
members of the officer's recommendation
is to to refuse this application is that
seconded
that's seconded by councilor chair
um
before I before I go to members there's
a few questions I'd like to ask the
officer
um
I understand the comments that you've
made about ashuden but I think we have
to accept based on recent appeals and
when I say recent appeals I mean going
all the way back probably four years
when a planning inspector said quite
clearly that ashudam was sustainable
location
and since then we've had lots of
properties built
um in in Ashland so could you just
clarify your thinking around why this is
not a sustainable location and and I
agree with what the applicant agent said
there is a bus service there which
actually is more frequent now than it
ever has been the D4
that have been
issued
recently
um
and
um
okay but I think we do have to accept
that there's an awful lot of properties
being built since the appeal that said
that ashram is a sustainable location so
I sort of hear what you're saying but
you know this has been going on for a
number of years and before I throw it
open the reason why I mentioned this
previous appeal do you have the copy of
the planning application that was
relevant to that appeal
do you have a drawing on it
[Music]
so obviously you stand by your
conclusion of 3.2.1 where it says the
impact of the proposed on the character
or the appearance of the area which was
which was I think what they appear
inspector said yes
dismiss Ed and as I mentioned
patient and breakfast was made
the um
you can just see by looking at this
majority of
this band on
the side of this problem in comparison
first is
significantly less than
[Music]
um
the next end
um
being smaller
screen aside
okay I think before I hand her over to
members Mr Lee
um just in relation to your first point
about accessibility just want to
highlight sections
5.2.12.2 and three within the office
report because I think they are
important and they do talk directly to
the points you raised and um that's the
second paragraph I highlighted actually
talks about a week and a relatively
recent appeal in 2019 at the wheat she
found but whereas certain says Paul
explains the relatively neutral comment
on about accessibility but also what it
did highlights is that it was actually
very limited information inspector when
determining this appeal and I'm sure
members have noted you know the level of
information officers are providing now
in relation to accessibility in relation
to bus footpath
Etc is much greater than it was
historically and the officers pulled
quite clearly explains the level of
frequency of public transport and you
know including the you know some of the
buses are actually just school buses
there's you know some of the buses don't
actually run up weekends Etc so the
actual availability of buses for
day-to-day use outside of potentially
core hours and Monday to Friday is very
limited and also in relation to the
specific location of this on the bend
and how this would actually make it less
attractive today
right
is
rice at the bottom of Russia's Lane
and it must be it must be
it must be a mile to the north and I
understand why that's not sustainable
because it's nowhere near the main road
and I think as far as buses are
concerned my understanding is the D4
once I think every hour and 15 minutes
um six or seven times a day so I think
the sustainability side of this is is
perhaps not what
officer maybe understands it to be based
on what's actually going on on the
ground but anyway I'll give way now
members cast the steps
foreign
and I think it is still
foreign
cancel the bill
Mr chairman um
sorry counselor just for the benefit of
everybody can you just tell us which
appear you're looking at
remember or can you tell us the address
never encouraged anyone to be waving
things off of the internet without
this is Advanced Warfare comment you
know uh we it should become a very
limited way and then open the boat just
saying but I I think if we go back to as
a starting point if we go back to the
appeal the first appeal that was allowed
was a Saint Ann's Farmhouse which is
sort of opposite diagonally opposite
homelands and that appeal was was upheld
and all of the issues around
sustainability and the inspector
disagreed with officers and then that
opened the open the floodgates of lots
of development in Ashburn I think at the
last count that I think that Mr cousins
did I think there were 12 properties
including the um the chairman of the
council's property as well you know just
to highlight what's gone on
and these have all been I think all of
these bad exception of being approved by
officers committed but that is obviously
on the sustainability grounds but there
is another aspect to the refusal which
is all to do with the impact on the on
the character of the area which is where
the inspector lead to last time
so I don't know if you want to come back
yeah
um two points one in relation to the uh
point about officers and the delegated
authority approving wedding
bands
it is
unless there was a principle already
accepted on site
um
and yes as always you know if members do
disagree with a single review so it
doesn't mean we have to throw them away
still be refused on the other as I
always
can I think that
okay so uh councilor change
is
on this side
so popular
applications
foreign
foreign
yeah of course
and it does concern me
um
organizations
fully consistent with this you know and
um obviously the two properties
unacceptable would be very similar to
what we would end up with if we've got
permission now so if members were to go
against the inspectors conclusion we'd
have to have some sort of
changing thought process of why the
inspector said it was unacceptable to
have two properties on this side and now
through two separate applications why
would it become acceptable and that's
just something members need to consider
decisions
application and I said if members don't
feel the site is
unsustainable that's within their gift
results
that you know we are we're literally in
an application which two different
applications we broadly consistent with
something that's already been dismissed
over here thank you
okay well I think members are millended
to uh
the
the elevation
that's
all we've got
so quite a hard profile
okay
so and then the plan itself
site
I mean yeah interestingly I think worse
disused
um
controls
um
[Music]
[Music]
is to go to the doctors
there's enough
so I feel it's very understandable
okay so this still leaves the issue
around
whether it's going to cause harm to the
character and appearance on the site in
the surrounding area which is what
um
if we could have
a great indictment of Ashton that's for
sure
no you've got the band the band was
built
seven seven or eight years ago the mum
was put up I think around about the time
maybe you dipped of the appeal we know
it's a very difficult Corner we know
that Essex County Council seems to be
working with everybody to try and
resolve this and and I think the
applicant's working with them as well
but yeah it's it's how this how this
building
fits in there that's what we're trying
to work out whether or not you know if
maybe if it was a slightly smaller roof
section members might feel more
comfortable about it
um
I don't think it can be screened any
more than what it is at the moment
because
no there's a that is a Bund which is
probably about as high as this
um
intimidating I mean I do the bends and
they don't bother me but going the other
way I think it's very very difficult to
drive
I don't think it's unsustainable
um
series of section 106 and have
highlights of that that was
important I didn't agree with
that well I I believe that you know we
can add a condition that the Rams
if members were minded to approve an
application as always we'd be
recommended and delegated to the
director subject to the completion of
the social 106.
which is obviously which members will be
aware of to understand as a
recommendation or anything with the new
dwelling to facilitate the EU to come
forward
future that's why
yeah I mean I mean clearly reconditioned
we can condition it and I mean it's
always useful if applicants subscribe to
that in advance to the planning
application
um so um sorry cancel the channel well
situation
I do feel to me it is an issue and I
actually
found my other themes of being said on
the field statements
previously
foreign
application according to the development
plan and this material considerations
indicate otherwise
this application is broadly consistent
with the previous estimates gone to
appeal and been found to be unacceptable
to a certain extent how we feel
personally is a moot point we need to
consider the development plan as
material situations indicate otherwise
and in a previous inspection decision is
a materialization of significant way and
we shouldn't just ignore that or cast
its side without some plan and Merit or
something that's changed that as a
material consideration so while I've
spent counselor stamps opinion you know
she doesn't actually have a problem with
it but my point that you'd be looking at
what did the inspector say what did the
inspectors conclude and has there been
something changed between now and then
that means that us as decision makers
can cast Society in space decision and
that would be my recommendation with
every appeal if you've heard me say this
at committee before and as always that
would just be my advice is that we
should be looking at the starting point
and if members are to go against this
recommendation the reason for approval
will need to talk to the appeal decision
and that would be where I'd be
struggling for members okay so look you
know I think the members find themselves
in a position of being disadvantaged
here because when you when I first read
this I thought to myself it's all going
to hinge around their field decision and
clearly it does
um you know personally I think if we had
a
a lower profile Bungalow with a lower
roof that sat on the site perhaps not so
visibly
on you know I I probably wouldn't have
an issue with that but we do have we do
have this appeal decision in the
background but unfortunately without
having sight of that appeal decision but
what the plans were
so like okay so is this the appeal
decision now on the so we've got the two
two two buildings
and have we got the elevations as well
but the the
so have you got any elevations at all or
do your channel so as Matthew said
earlier I could say is that the
is the the current bungalows in a more
prominent location compared to where the
two were producing where the inspector
found that to be unacceptable so the
migration of this Bungalow in my
professional opinion has exacerbated the
harm that the inspector found to be
unacceptable not alleviated it so I
think you know it was always you know
that pill decision is a starting point
for us as decision makers and as always
it's a consideration when officers bring
forward their reports so if we go if we
just if we go back to this application
on the plan the site plan
foreign
which shows the existing dwelling in the
proposed one
yeah
so
the existing dwelling looks as though
it's a different footprint than one that
went to
appealand yeah
is
um okay thanks
look when we were when we dealt with
Burnham Waters phase three the the the
report that went to the district
planning committee had lots and lots of
references and lots of information in
there about the previous appeal and
everything else and I just think by not
having that information in front of us
now we're disadvantaged and I think that
that also disadvantaged the applicant
um so
um
my proposal would be that we defer this
to allow members to
get the information on this appeal
perhaps get the agent to look more
closely at this and perhaps pick up some
of the comments that have been made
about roof lines and everything else
so uh we have a proposal that we defer
this because I think it's only fair to
the applicant so that we fully
understand this appeal and how
because I think members are trying to be
supportive as much as they can but
without that information they can't make
the decision and we shouldn't make the
wrong decision tonight so which you know
it might be in the applicant's favor I
think listening to this to wait so I
propose that this is deferred to
enabling us to have more information
that's been seconded by councilman Helm
is that agreed
oh sorry okay so the first proposal
which was uh post the second year was to
refuse those in favor
which is to defer this application to
allow further information to come
forward in relation to the appeal so
that we can make properly informed
decision which I think would be best for
everybody is that
agreements of procedure should we not
vote on against the proposal
um well yeah okay if everyone abstained
in theory would have been well carried
it's uh it's well my understanding is is
that one person voted and and that that
would put it to bed and I think that
obviously I'm not here to do procedure
you can just advise me so okay not
anymore but okay then so I will now put
the other emails or knowing that we've
now got we've got one that's well I'm
still not quite sure that procedurally
we run but I know bear in mind we've
already agreed now the committee has
agreed to diverse but just for the Peace
of Mind Council Helm I'll now put the
proposal that we agreed this all in
favor please show well
to agree the planning application
recommendation okay so uh well I I put
the vote those who say I to the
officer's recommendation to refuse and
we all said we only one person supported
there so if everyone was abstained that
would then be refused so that's what you
need to do it
yeah you'll make an assumption
you now need to have a vote to refuse it
offices
right so Madam Clarke I put the
officer's recommendation which was which
I proposed right at the beginning of the
debate and which councilor Channel
second and the the result of that was
one in favor and everybody else uh
abstained
so so okay then if ever understand then
that was refused that that was that was
oh I see what you mean yeah yeah I see
what you mean so we've actually refused
it yeah
[Music]
no I'm not here to give it I'm not here
to get the advice to the process with
Miss Casey we're we're
foreign
application well okay the the planning
applications therefore be refused
and then So the plan the application has
been confused I am not sure that whether
or not whether or not I can come back
now and say it's going to be deferred
because I actually think now that's why
I wanted to put the deferral first
councilor hell give me
I don't think we can now because it's
been refused
[Music]
what it's been it doesn't matter I think
Council Janna I think based on what you
said nobody else voted and it's been
refused so we've unfortunately lost that
opportunity even though I made a
proposal that we were going to defer
this
so I'm afraid we are where we are
well I put my proposal
what to do to refuse well it was it was
properly it was properly
um it was properly proposed and properly
settled and upon the vote being taken
um the refusal
was upheld by the committee
attention
um
sorry sorry it's
not sure
foreign
listen I think probably go get thinking
this through my mind I think that we've
had that vote and I think that now it
would be remiss of me not to put it to
the committee
um
whether whether or not we well we voted
to refuse we've voted to refuse
foreign
I think the question I need to put now
is we put the vote and I think the
councilor Channel voted to refuse it and
then
um what I'm going to say now is do we
agree to refuse it
yeah so all those against
right so that now that that now negates
that which now brings me back to mine
um recommendation that seemed to put a
long time ago that we defer it to our
house to have more information on the
appeal so that we can reconsider it with
the correct amount of information
is that agreed that's
so uh that's that's agreed by the
community but councilor channel has
voted against doing that so
so uh right so that now clear as mud but
that's now been deferred and and I hope
that
based on what I said before I hope the
applicant
listens to what's being said and perhaps
takes a steer and hopefully we can move
this forward to a satisfactory
conclusion for everybody at our next
meeting so uh
together
right so uh there any other business
there is no any other business so I
close the meeting at 8 34. thank you